but are electric vehicles really the
answer to how we'll all need to get
around in the future once petrol and
diesel cars are phased out vicky what do
you think of this are electric cars the
future in your view
i think they are the future but of
course for the moment they are still
quite costly to produce they emit quite
a lot of uh you know co2 in the
production of them uh and uh they are
very expensive for most people uh and of
course they rely on batteries which need
to improve very significantly i think it
is worth bearing in mind that there are
loads of um
technologies of the future that we're
going to be depending on and battery is
going to be one of them um if they're
sorted out properly in terms of the
range that they allow you to have
and also in terms of the cost of
producing them and whatever you do with
you know once they run out of their
lifetime themselves uh in fact disposing
of them then uh of course evs are a way
of getting around in the future and i
think definitely the investment needs to
go there but we're not there yet okay
and let's take a look at a few stats
donakur because um we can see that in
august 2021 so last month it's that we
saw a 32.2
increase in pure electric car sales in
the uk that compares to the same month
the year before so consumer demand
clearly on the up but do you think they
solve our green transport issues
um electric vehicles are
an excellent response for emergency
vehicles and essential vehicles
but there are 1.4 billion vehicles on
the planet
let's take an average of 10 tons of
carbon to to create one of those
then you're talking about something like
14 billion tons of carbon emitted to
switch our fleet over that's 3.5 of our
remaining carbon budget
for one car somebody buys a new ev or a
new diesel car this year you're talking
between 10 to 30 years of the
electricity missions for their
households so you're basically saying
you shouldn't drive at all we should
give up
all cars including electric ones
well something like 70 of trips in the
uk are under two miles
we actually need to switch to public
transport and walking and cycling for
this for those journeys
evs are fine for emergency vehicles but
we can't we and the positive thing about
us if we do that we get cleaner cities
we get safer streets and our kids can be
playing in in neighborhoods again vicki
price do you think that's right that our
main focus really needs to be on public
transport and if absolutely possible we
should give up our cars
well the investment that needs to go
into public transport improvements is
huge and we're not going to get that
done and it's not just us of course here
in the uk i mean look what's going on
elsewhere look at the us for example
where cars are absolutely essential the
public transport uh system doesn't work
look at the developing countries too one
way of getting around that is through
electric vehicles of course the the
lifetime
savings that you make in terms of energy
are very significant and of course you
don't pollute the environment the way
that uh cars are present do so uh yes i
don't think that uh you know moving out
of driving completely is the answer uh
in my view and i think ev's give you a
very very substantial way of achieving
the climate change goals you need both
major looting problems um
sorry we're out of time but i'll leave
you shaking your head there thank you
and vicky both very much indeed